there is an absolutely brutal new poll
in which Donald Trump is losing to Ron
DeSantis by 13 in the 2024 Republican
primary let's talk about it but wait
what you you like trust polls man or
what remember that moment from my
interview with Patrick Bett David in
Florida a couple weeks ago well listen I
mean let's talk about it right when we
look at polls there are three important
questions that we ask is the pollster
highly rated and historically reliable
that's an important question second
question is this one poll dramatically
different than every other poll if you
have 20 polls 19 say one thing and one
says something else we would want to
understand why that is and is there
something in particular about the
subject matter or the timing that makes
polling on a particular issue inherently
unreliable so it's not about pollster
quality it's just about this is a really
hard thing or it's a really hard time to
be asking people about this subject
matter so let's ask that question okay a
new Monmouth poll has Donald Trump
losing to Ron DeSantis who is not even
running yet
by 13 points in a hypothetical
Republican primary that's 53 for
DeSantis to 40 for Trump now that is a
hypothetical head-to-head if you end up
having Nikki Haley run she's expected to
announce soon if you've got Mike Pompeo
Mike Pence maybe other people named Mike
or maybe some people not named Mike
you are going to have different numbers
this is a hypothetical Head to Head now
let's run through our questions is
Monmouth a good pollster the answer is
yes Monmouth is an a-rated pollster by
538 uh even morning consult which is
often used by corporate media it's only
a b-rated pollster uh youga Yahoo poll
which is very much used as well is a B
plus so yes our first question Monmouth
is a good pollster is this poll an
outlier compared to others in a sense it
is okay and so we can look at 5 38's
recent Republican primary polls and the
results are sort of off the map uh not
often up the result the results are all
over the map and so depending on where
you look there's a primary poll from The
Economist from a few days ago that one
has Trump plus 10 but there's a lot of
undecideds there you look at a yougov
poll it has Trump up to in Trump versus
DeSantis you look at a morning consult
poll from about a week ago and that one
has Trump plus 18. so in a sense yes the
Monmouth poll is a little bit of an
outlier although you can find polling
here that does have DeSantis leading
there's a yugav Yahoo news poll which
has DeSantis plus four
um when it's asked in a different way
without other candidates head to head so
the general answer to is this an outlier
is when the polling is Trump versus
DeSantis only it does seem to be pretty
good for Ron DeSantis when the polling
includes other candidates or it doesn't
Force an answer and lets you put I don't
know haven't decided yet or whatever
then it seems to be better for Donald
Trump and then we get to the third
question I mentioned is this something
we can even really get good data on in
February of the year before for the
election
yes and no you know valuable polling
data
without a clear field
unclear about whether Trump is going to
get indicted unclear what Joe Biden's
next two years are going to look like
and what Republicans are going to run on
and what voters are going to want there
is a limit to how valuable today's
polling data is it doesn't mean the
polling is inaccurate based on what
Republican voters are saying right now
it's a broader question which is does
this type of poll
uh what is it 9 plus 12 21 months before
an election well and in this particular
case more more like 17 months before the
primary is going to be of some limited
value what this polling will do
is it will brutally trigger Donald Trump
and possibly explode this Feud Civil War
that is building between Donald Trump
and Ron DeSantis and that's what we're
going to talk about next
one of our sponsors today is zipx
nicotine toothpicks zippix brings you a
convenient alternative to smoking and
vaping and The Vape clouds the ashtrays
the thing in your lip that people can
see I've seen that around this is an
easier and less messy way to curb the
cravings and you can use zipx just about
anywhere zipx is available in six
flavors with two or three milligram
strength the nicotine and the flavor are
long lasting and zipix has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and
they are bad habits zipx toothpicks are
FDA registered their customer service is
second to none it is one of the most
cost effective Alternatives also check
out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks
see for yourself why so many people have
switched to zipx 2 picks you can only
get zipx online go to zipxtoothpix.com
and get 10 off with the code Pacman the
link is down below